what's going on guys this is rob and i
considered uh taking the entire moon
night like the first volume right the
first six issues throwing them all into
one video but this one i want to do
separate um i want to do this one on its
own and the reason why is because one
there's a lot to unpack here and two i
want you guys to get a good idea of what
jed mckay is doing here right because
this guy
man this moon night story is amazing
it's so good so far and it's only the
first issue so initially we pick up here
with what are basically like vampires
right now one of the things to keep in
mind is that marvel has a pretty tight
continuity going on right now relatively
speaking right so wolverine is largely
dealing with the events of dracula and
that kind of stuff but it also crossed
over a little bit with the avengers and
it's also happening here now one of the
big differences between moon knight and
a lot of characters like spider-man or
the incredible hulk or something like
that is that moon knight was part of the
midnight suns and so because of that
there's a lot of like the monster dark
you know vampire that kind of thing that
goes on in the moon night stories not
consistently right sometimes he's just
beating up bad guys but more often than
not it's the dark monster side of marvel
that you see moon knight dealing with
here and so the idea is that with
everything models doing at the moment i
don't know if they're going to make like
a vampire centric event i kind of hope
they don't but dracula has been trying
to get his hands on various samples of
blood right like the blood of the
incredible hulk or like the blood of
wolverine blood that can be used due to
its healing factor properties that would
allow vampires to basically consume it
and then automatically heal from the sun
so basically become day walkers
essentially and so that's why you have
these guys here right you have vampires
here who have just newly turned some
younger people into vampires and then
kind of send them out there while they
are saying that like you know you guys
are our subordinates so when you turn
other people into vampires those people
will become your subordinates the idea
is to simply just expand the number of
vampires as fast as humanly possible
right that's or at least as fast as
possible not really humanly possible but
as fast as possible that's dracula's
motivation here and that's why a lot of
people are doing this of course in the
middle of it all you're basically beset
by moon knight now the funny thing about
this and kind of what moon knight says
is that he has this kind of area of new
york cordoned off right he has little
symbols and stuff that he puts around in
the shape of a moon and he puts those
there as a warning sign right to let
people know not to cross into his
territory and that's what he says he's
like i paint my symbol on the walls for
two reasons the first is so people know
they're safe my people people traveling
at night the second is a warning to
anybody who would harm those people at
night and so that's why he basically
goes after those vampires and then kills
him now that's one thing that i do want
to establish when it comes to moon
knight for those of you guys who are
unfamiliar with him right to the
uninitiated moon knight will kill people
he's he's not like that i mean he is
like he's basically marvel's batman the
difference is that he's not a half
measure right batman's a half measure he
won't really kill anybody moon knight
will right moon knight will be like that
guy needs to go but there's actually
there's a little more to his character
besides that which we'll explore over
the course of the story and where he
moves in on these newly created vampires
their response is no no right we're not
those guys like we don't want to be
vampires one of them was apparently a
vegan and then in turn they're like we
don't want to do anything to anybody
right like we just want to be left alone
now the irony of this is that because
they are vampires they are going to have
to consume blood at some point along the
line now one of the things that happens
with that in marvel is you do see
occasionally and like a blade comic or
something like that where somebody like
blade will let a vampire go and then
tell them like go over there right go to
some blood bank and get your your your
blood if you need to that's what michael
morbius did in the early days in comics
and even to a degree that's what he did
when he became something of an anti-hero
he never fed on human blood if he didn't
need to right he hated the idea of doing
that so it's not uncommon to see people
who are vampires in marwa comics find
alternative methods to killing innocent
people in order to satiate their their
blood appetite and mark specter is
basically going on a limb here right
because these guys say no no we don't
want to do that he's basically trusting
them and that's kind of the irony
because you switch over to him having a
conversation with his therapist dr
sturman and in turn she's like so you
let them go and in response moonlight's
like yes right reese basically his
assistant was correct in saying that
like they're they're vampires but
they're also innocent people he said
they had been kidnapped and turned by
some vampiric self-actualized pyramid
scheme cult they were also travelers at
night and they needed my protection and
so that's when the questions asked so
it's your righteous duty right let's
talk about that did you start a church
and the response of moon night is yes i
started a mission right i am the high
priest of konshu now here's one of the
things to understand when it comes to
muni right really what kind of goes on
here is basically the origin story of
mark spector to a degree but one of the
things to know is that mark specter
struggles with disassociative identity
disorder in terms of his initial origin
he was basically exactly what it looks
like he started out as mark spector he
was in the u.s marine corps he joined
the cia they did private military
contracting basically throughout you
know africa and south america but that's
when he says like private military
contracting right like don't sanitize it
down he was a mercenary right he would
kill for money but eventually a time
came when he was working alongside royal
bushmen when they were essentially
trying to find this treasure hall
basically when they were working
alongside the professor who had located
the statue of konchu that in turn mark
spector turned against ron bushman and
in fact more or less had a change of
heart rall bushman shot him for dead or
left him for dead and then in turn he's
left at the statue at the base of the
statue of konchu and that's when konshu
visited him and said i will make you my
earthly avatar i will bring you back if
you promise to serve me right and that's
how mark spector became moon knight and
that's what he says right like i did go
a conscience but after years of fighting
dirty wars my soul was barren earth to
sprout such a flower is that well it had
to be watered with blood my blood and so
she says you claim that the egyptian god
conscious brought you back to life and
his answer is yes i was given my life
back in return for becoming the fist of
konshu to become the traveler the
embracer the pathfinder the defender of
those who travel at night and that was
the original nature of moon knight of
mark spector back in the days when he
first showed up he was a very capable
fighter because of all of his training
and everything like that but in the full
moon and at night his powers would
actually expand at night his powers
already grew when there was a full moon
his powers would amplify even further
but he very much was a night-based
villain right he would fight at night
and that's why a lot of people began to
draw these sort of illusions between
himself and batman because they had so
much in common and so that's when you
find out right where where sermon is
kind of like okay i mean like as a
therapist what you're describing to me
sounds like schizophrenia right
basically the idea that you betrayed
your partner you were left to the base
of a statue that statue came to you
right like that god came to you and
promised to resurrect you as long as you
would be their agent on earth and you've
gone forward fighting an avenging crime
in their name that sounds like a person
who cannot differentiate reality from
fantasy now the diagnosis of
schizophrenia takes more than that it's
not something that's made on a whim but
mark puts off all the hallmark
perceptions or all the harm work
perspectives of schizophrenia to a
person that doesn't that wouldn't really
understand what's going on but then she
goes as far as to say i i have agreed to
be your therapist at the request of the
avengers so i understand that your
situation is unique so that's why she
doesn't immediately chalk him up and say
okay like mark it sounds like you're
schizophrenic that's what it sounds like
right i mean literally she's in a world
of people where like a guy turns into a
giant greed rage monster giant 2000 foot
tall space gods show up routinely i mean
it's
at this point right mark's situation
seems to be less mental illness and more
of just a mission he has but mental
illness does exist in mobile comics
legion is a perfect example of that the
difficult thing in marvel comics is
trying to differentiate which characters
or which characters are who they claim
to be and which characters are
schizophrenic right which ones are just
imagining it all in their heads but the
thing about this is that the mission of
moon knight is very reminiscent of one
when he was mr knight right that's the
version that you see here and then two
of like heroes for hire but it's very
very similar to that now mark's always
kind of had this sort of thing going on
to a degree even if it wasn't
necessarily as on the face as it is
right now it's always basically been
that way people could come to him and
they could say hey like i'm dealing with
some crazy stuff right um i need you to
help me out with that and it's kind of
funny because he's talking to this older
lady and she's like you know in my
building they come at night they scratch
the doors they whisper such things you
know she's like i need you to help me
out now this is probably the coolest
moment the comic because you switch over
to moon knight basically pummeling these
things and like one of the occupants
opens the door while he's beating the
crap out of these these monster things
in the hallway and he's like close the
door right close the door and lock it
and so as he like pummels all these guys
he throws one of them out the window and
basically kills it he tells the other
ones like i know who you are right
vermin one of spider-man's foes some mad
science guinea pig you used to be a man
and you hate being alone and so now
you've cloned yourself so you will never
be alone but he says unless i kill all
of you right now and i can and i will i
am not spider-man i am moon knight and i
don't die and it's just a ridiculously
cool moment right this is a ridiculously
amazing moment right like he literally
like he literally tells all these guys
you tried to take one of mine and i took
one of yours so either you can leave it
at that you can scurry off and you can
stay out of my territory or you can test
me further and i can kill you all right
and like all those little vermin
basically end up scurrying off that's
the essence of moon knight right like
that's the essence of of mark spector is
he's just like he'll he doesn't really
care right the rules don't really apply
to him he will kill people i mean that's
just the way that it is right he doesn't
really have any of these kind of higher
moral high grounds right because the
higher moral high grounds like those
don't really work right all it does is
give villains a reason or an excuse to
continue being villains right because
they know you'll only go so far and they
kind of rely on your inability to to be
a full measure as a means by which they
can continue what they do right but when
you're mark specter and you're not a
half measure right you're a full measure
right and you will kill those guys
villains don't usually mess with you
right they don't usually come to your
part of town and start giving you a hard
time they usually steer clear for the
most part and so again you kind of
switch over to this conversation that's
going on when you have uh sturman
basically talking to moon knight and
andy eddie kind of goes through this he
sort of continues to establish what his
role is especially in relation to
khanshu now kanshu is an actual god out
there and one of the things to know is
that it's not as okanche was just some
kind of benevolent being or he doesn't
really exist in the same capacity as
vast in terms of like you know his
beliefs and views or anything like that
conscious very manipulative and more
recently in the avengers comics kanchu
tried to use mark spector and the
phoenix force as a way to conquer the
world of course mark specter basically
brought all that to an end and ended up
essentially defeating konchu in the
process and then khan shi was taken by
the asgardians and basically locked away
right so he is wherever he is under
asgardian control and he even says that
right like they're keeping him off in
asgard somewhere uh and it doesn't
really matter to me sure the god that i
that that i worship apparently the god
that created me yes like he is a person
i don't trust we stand apart but he says
i am still the high priest of a god that
i am estranged from so even though i do
not necessarily even follow khanshu i
have no desire to rescue khanshu or to
help him i am still maintaining my role
which is to protect those who travel at
night you know kind of going back in and
and in turn uh basically visiting what
is in effect like a clinic you know he's
told by rhys that like some super
villain was attacking it when he gets
there he's like well it doesn't look
like this villain is doing a very good
job cause this villain like eight ball
eight ball sucks it doesn't matter but
he's getting the absolute crap beat out
of him right getting absolutely pummeled
by the owner of this clinic so he's not
a very good super villain but the cool
thing is this guy this this kind of
seems a little bit off right this guy
basically says like when moon knight
asks him you know he was like uh what's
the whole deal here and this guy he says
his name is dr bader he's like uh this
guy was attacking my clinic right you
know so basically i beat the crap out of
him but i was always wondering when i
might meet you right so words
circulating around the neighborhood that
mark specter is the one who protects the
neighborhood he's the one that keeps
people safe and that's an important
distinction that's how mobsters rose to
power back in the day and it's how
people are really able to avoid
prosecution by the law in a lot of ways
is because they protect the neighborhood
so the neighborhood protects them so
it's one of those things where like if
mark specter does something that he's
not supposed to do or something that
could lead to him getting arrested the
people in the neighborhood follow the
philosophy of well i didn't see anything
because i wasn't there and if i was
there while i was asleep right but they
would never rat on him right they would
never snitch right they kind of keep to
themselves because they know at the end
of the day mark is looking out for them
in a way that seemingly nobody else will
and there's loyalty that gets built up
there and so that's what's kind of
interesting is because the conversation
between the two of them kind of begins
to shift to a degree and this guy you
know dr badir is like you know you're a
fist of conscious mr specter right you
have a sacred duty this guy seems to
know a lot right like mark says like the
fists of kanchu and i don't remember
seeing you at the church social right
like mark has his own event and kind of
hanging out and all that kind of stuff
and this guy's like consider me recently
arrived from the home office i was
disappointed with what i see our god
languishes in the custody of foreign
deities and what is his fist doing
allowing vampires to exist in territory
consecrated to the duty of khanshu
absurd blasphemous and so basically he's
calling mark spector's entire role into
question right that he almost kind of
seems to have this sort of belief in
conch right like he almost seems to be
equivalent to mark spector in terms of
the role that he plays and that's when
he's kind of like look i mean if you
know you're supposed to be a fist of
kanchu why aren't you rescuing konshu
why aren't you out there helping him out
like all you're really doing here is
you're you're like vampires are getting
in around here and stuff like that like
you're basically being exceedingly
ineffective at your job and you've
basically abandoned your boss and that's
when mark's like okay what in the
world's going on here now this is an
important distinction here right what
mark's basically saying is that he's not
the only fist of conscious out there
he's not the only agent of khan shu that
exists out there in the world but he
sees himself as the highest ranking
right he is the fist of kanchu he was
chosen by khanshu to operate on earth
and to be his agent but this guy
basically chimes back and says i can
assure you mr specter there is but one
who outranks me in the cult of konshu
and you are not him and so that's what's
so crazy here is you switch back to this
conversation between dr sturman and uh
and mark spector and they hit on the
idea about his disassociative identity
disorder now this was a hallmark of mark
spector and it actually took a little
while to get up to that point it was it
was it was like this this story arc that
basically took decades to build but the
idea is that when mark specter
officially became moon knight that what
he needed was the ability to operate on
multiple levels and so he created the
jake lockley identity to basically be a
cab driver right the guy that can have
his ear to the ground and hear about
what's going on on the street level then
he developed the steve grant identity
who's the ultra wealthy guy basically
the bruce wayne of marvel so he can hear
what's going on out there in terms of
white white-collar crime and he could
fight all of them equally and that in
essence the various personalities or
identities that he created became
personalities to the point that he
didn't even know who he was anymore he
didn't know if his real identity was
steve grant or jake lockley or mark
spector if his life as a mercenary was
actually something he made up and he's
always been a cab driver because he
developed whole identities for himself
right like whole backgrounds in
everything whole stories the whole nine
yards so we could blend in and so with
all that meshing together it all really
came to a head i would argue in jeff
lemire's moon night run when ultimately
he had to basically destroy those
personalities but it's one of the things
that dr sermon talks about that she
deals with superhuman menticide right
cases like jack monroe and rutherford
winner now jack monroe is particularly
interesting because if i recall
correctly jack monroe was the guy who
played the fake bucky barnes i think
okay so here's the deal here's the rub
cut a side track from moon knight for a
second the way this worked as most of
you guys know captain america it was
basically frozen in a block of ice at
the end of world war ii and bucky barnes
was believed to have been dead after
being blown up by the plane that he was
on with uh by uh by baron zemo but
marvel kept producing captain america
comics going into the cold war and so
eventually the question had to be asked
if captain america was a was appearing
in like the cold war era but he was
supposed to have been frozen in ice and
died during world war ii then how did
those two things reconcile and so over
the years different writers had given us
different bits of information ed
brubaker had actually consolid all of
that down in his just landmark captain
america run and then in turn gave us
characters like jack monroe basically
revealing that steve rogers captain
america and the original james buchanan
barnes yes they had been gone since the
end of world war ii what you got were
stand-ins you basically got people
pretending to be steve rogers and
pretending to be bucky barnes because
the country wasn't ready for the reality
the captain america could have been
killed because with the death of captain
america people would see that as the
death of america you get what i mean so
it was more like political and
propaganda than it was anything else but
jackman rose struggled with like
disassociative identity disorder for
years after playing buckybarn that along
with things like ptsd depression anxiety
and so on the guy's entire life was just
turned upside down right it was it was
absolutely crazy but that's one of the
reasons why she deals with people like
jack monroe because it gives you
perception as far as how reaching her
role is and dealing with these various
people around here but switching back to
mark kind of there back at his facility
he ends up hanging out with rhys now
again it's kind of cool to see that he's
just given risa roll right i mean
reese's i mean while she was one of the
vampires in the beginning she's still
pretty sassy right like earlier in the
comic uh he was like hey can you get us
some coffee she's like get it yourself
right so she's she's she's a little
jerky to a degree but it's also she's
also entertaining but again one of the
reasons why he says he likes having her
here so much is because she doesn't try
to change it right like she's perfectly
fine with the way he is and he prefers
to be the way that he is and so again as
the two of them are talking and he says
like it's it's not easy to do this when
everyone thinks you're crazy and it's
even harder to do it when they when they
when like they're right that you are
crazy but it's like it's my job to do my
job is to basically be the fist of
kanchu and as he kind of goes on about
his role it being his sacred duty you
end up finding out that basically dr
badir is watching him that this guy is
just keeping an eye on him and that he
simply says that like his goal is to
literally start working on mark spector
right that he's turning mark spector
into his own project right he's
basically going to take this guy down
and the reason why is that it's
seemingly a personal vendetta that where
this guy shows up to a statue of konchu
that he says like he's a defender right
that mark specter that moon knight that
he's errored right that he strayed away
from the purpose of kanchu that moon
knight requires correction and he says
but i keep the faith i enact your will i
will carry out your duty and he says
your right hand has failed but your left
hand has not your other fist remains
faithful your hunter's moon so basically
this guy is now the new main villain of
moon knight seemingly and he's the other
hand of konshu i'm excited to see where
this goes man because i'm not aware of
this guy having ever appeared before but
it looks great so with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace